let's welcome team 21 okay we're reality
policy we are Helen Muriel and Mary so
we all know that in every community
there could be more more engagement for
students with stem taking a look at my
school district schaumburg district 54
outside of Chicago Illinois we are a
majority minority district all
elementary kids in our district are
exposed to really rich stem activities
still we find that when kids move on to
the junior high lots of girls and
underrepresented minorities aren't
taking advantage of those opportunities
that they get a junior high as an
example we have a jumps program that
hosts 300 students that's girls engaged
in math and science but what we find is
that less than ten percent or
african-american and about fifteen
percent are Hispanic so in districts
like this there is a door to opportunity
but not all students are going through
the door and our solution to this
problem is to create a new staff
position called the stem community
liaison and this could be one or more
people per district based on the
community means so the stem community
liaisons will link the schools with stem
programs the stem industry that are
looking for future workers and also the
families in the community and the
liaisons will create personal one-to-one
relationships with the students and
parents and also provide information and
resources to parents in their native
language if that is needed so here's an
example what a liaison would do in one
week a Monday you could see the liaison
connecting with community partners such
as hospitals businesses and they're
connecting real-world experiences
outside the classroom so you give these
children the opportunities on Tuesday
you see the liaison visiting science
classrooms and interacting with students
on the third day on Wednesday you see
that they're reaching out to parents in
their native language using bilingual
flyers and also making personal phone
calls so again you're making this real
relationship with the families directly
and on Thursday you could see our
liaison communicating on the online
platform and Friday you could see them
also gathered all
at this event again with the partners
liaisons the parents and the students
all around stem events thank you thank
you guys so much how do you think the
parents would react to losing the direct
linkage to the teachers I don't think
anybody is suggesting that you would
lose the direct link to this to the
parents and to the teachers but I think
what the stem liaison would do is kind
of another layer of that to say you know
like if we have a large Hispanic
population I'm going to call you and I'm
gonna speak to you in your native
language and I'm gonna say hey we're
having this great event this week your
student has an awesome thing that they
made I hope that we'll see you there i
hope you'll come in and then again at
the event they're going to be there to
welcome parents in again in their native
language so they're feeling comfortable
but definitely the teacher is going to
be there too and the teachers always
going to be you know connecting with the
with the family as you guys I'm is more
like a support to the teacher and
network between the industry you're
discriminating so English speakers would
have direct access and speak with the
teachers and non-english because I would
still communicate with the English
speakers but we're saying we were
supplemented as you I have different
types of family liaisons you really need
to look at your particular school
district so you could have liaisons that
speak different languages and English
speakers I mean the point is that you
want to have access so everyone can
communicate and understand did you in
terms of cost sharing for this new FTE
for districts did you think about not
burdening the district anymore with
another higher but cost sharing with
local tech groups or yeah absolutely so
we're connecting back to to industry so
I think that we would hope that it would
be a win-win for industry to maybe
donate some money to this as well as you
know what they're doing is they're
letting the district know these are the
skills that we need workers to have 15
20 years from now so they're helping to
develop that that workforce those skills
that people are going to need as well as
maybe giving back to the district and
looking great to their community would
entice a i'm already paying my taxes
take it out of that
Sara Lee I think you know I think
corporations want to be good corporate
stewards